this is the most amazing sirloin you can
see it's got that wonderful marble for
me the secret behind this
is cooking it quickly season the steaks
generously
salt and pepper
push that seasoning in to the sirloin
take the third one out the fridge
literally 20 minutes before you want to
cook them so it gets up to room
temperature they cook more evenly but
more importantly you can actually season
right inside
the steak this little bit of fat down
here season that as well because that is
what we want to roast and get that
really nice and rendered olive oil in a
tablespoon
roll that round
as it starts to smoke in with the steaks
into the pan
and lay away
again into the pan
and lay away if you don't hear that
noise the minute those steaks hit the
pan don't put them in so the secret now
is getting that color on the steak
turning it once and once only and
cooking it for two and a half minutes
each side what i want to do is to get
that bit of fat rendered so it adds a
lot more flavor just hold
the steak down like that
and that starts to melt the fat which
makes it so much more tender there
should be no white fat left anywhere
turn them over
really important to have that steak up
to room temperature before you start
cooking it so the inside is nice and
warm so we spend less time in the pan
and more time cooling down really
important
now
two fingers touch
it goes in says rare
i'm happy for them to be rare because by
the time i let them rest
they're gonna go back to medium rare
it'll continue cooking out onto a plate
and let them rest
one
two
let's get my juices over
don't waste that really important
next the spicy dressing take the seeds
out of a chili to reduce the heat by
rubbing it in your hands and tapping
until the seeds fall out
cut it in half
and just chop it
in
garlic and chilli works brilliantly a
quick way of peeling it get your knife
and just
slam it down
pops out very very quickly in a little
touch of salt
rub
start going around in circles first
you'll see it puring
nice clear that off
now we've got the heat in there from the
chilli and that richness from the garlic
two teaspoons of palm sugar this is
where it starts to have that nice sweet
sour effect
fish sauce
fresh lime this is a simple fresh chili
dressing and it was something i fell in
love with in vietnam
and cambodia because it was just so easy
give that a little mix and dissolve
the sugar
quick taste
wow right vegetables
a great fuss-free way to get super thin
ribbons of carrot is to use a veg peeler
when they're that thin they take the
vinaigrette so much better and radishes
just slice them down at an angle
[Music]
lovely to give another dimension to the
salad and these are banana shallot they
are incredibly mellow
very sweet
across
just chop up
the shallot
and mix that through
want some sweetness in there now little
vine tomatoes slice them
in half smart is in
shallot radish carrots and tomatoes
next peel and slice cucumber
chopped spring onions and shred baby gem
lettuce and then finally get some fresh
mint there's young men so you don't need
to take all those stalks off all you do
is hold the bunch upside down and then
take it for a little
trim just chop that once
through
look at that nice
minted
salad
couple of tablespoons of dressing don't
flood the salad with a dressing we can
always add but we can't take it away now
really mix that dressing in there make
sure all that chili and garlic and palm
sugar wraps around that salad beautiful
onto the plate the steak's rested it's
now nice and medium rare a little bit of
fat we don't want to find that in the
salad just slice that off that serves
its purpose
it's kept that steak nice and moist
just slice going with the grain it's
almost like
slicing through butter and look inside
beautiful pink
besides the beef too thinly then it goes
stone cold and more importantly all the
goodness runs out of it
nice thick slices
get the beef and start placing it around
the salad
take a little teaspoon
of your dressing the rest of your salad
sip that on top
we'll finish it off with some toasted
peanuts peanuts in
now those nuts
are really toasted nuts on
get another pan and just
crush
once they've cooled down just run them
through with a knife
i can hear how crunchy they are another
texture another taste the salad
and then from there sprinkle
and then finally
take that
just finish it with a little
tablespoon of that sauce
and there is one tasty very well
textured spicy beef salad
[Music]
a few simple cuts through the rind means
the chop stays flat and cooks evenly
this really helps to cook the bird
evenly because you're pushing out all
the empty spaces